[Music]
so rob schneider
has is a stapler rob schneider has been
going on a bunch of different shows
i thought this could just not hiding his
power level at all yeah so i thought
this clip and by the way credit to rob
schneider for a few things man rob
schneider goes on [ __ ] glenn beck or
[ __ ] bill maher or [ __ ] he doesn't
care you know i like that you said
credit credit to rob schneider for a few
things yeah a few things they're all
adam sandler movies
i think he'll admit that
um
he went on tiger belly
now keep in mind
that rob
doesn't know anything about any of these
people no he just doesn't you could tell
if you watch the whole thing
but
what when i when i when i'm what i'm
seeing here is um
well how about i just play it tell me
who this is describing okay
who says this then what is information
that you shouldn't
divulge that you do know then what would
be stuff like you don't all right
what would you feel
with something that you would find that
you would know that maybe you shouldn't
say you shouldn't divulge because it's
not helpful like for instance if i would
tell you this like i knew a very very
talented um
uh oncologist this doctor at uh
yeah up in northern california i
shouldn't just narrow it down yeah and
uh his wife was cheating on him and we
knew for sure i said i'm not saying
nothing
was it to the guy next to you
you know it's always good too when you
get like a
huge star like rob schneider in your
show is to just talk over on brendan job
style yeah
no no no but like me though but like me
but like me i'm wondering is this an
older interview because this looks like
the older set can somebody let me know
this might be a clip from an older i
don't want to be one of our maybe have
two sets i don't know i think this is
old but it doesn't seem it but but that
looks like a different set right than
the other one that they do
it backfired so horribly
and um he was able to convince her that
he hadn't cheated anyways and now i look
like the homewrecker so
ma'am
ma'am ma'am ma'am
ma'am he's talking to you
not only
you're right you [ __ ]
two of your brothers and used to jerk
off dogs but we want we wouldn't want we
wouldn't want anybody to call you a
homewrecker a dog [ __ ] or a brother
[ __ ] so this is from two years ago
oh okay is that what you said yes sir
okay thank you
home wrecker so i still together yeah
wow with kids two kids now
is this about brendan
can we hear that again
hold on a second who's she talking about
um he was able to convince her that he
hadn't cheated anyways and now i look
like the home wrecker so i still
together yeah wow with kids two kids now
wow i tried to tell her what he had is
that a low self-esteem thing what is
hey
question
does that sound
like she's describing brendan to you or
am i crazy
brendan has two kids right am i correct
by saying that
yes that's the old saying thank you
sword and scale yes yields that's what i
thought
um
hmm
[Music]
did somebody stay in a relationship like
that has two kids i don't know i think
that he she really believes that i was
trying to somehow i think there's
something where where there's like you
have a dominant person and then there's
this
they're older
that's very funny thank you uh podboy
for this by the way somebody who just
refuses to ever become dominant yeah
well there's a thumbnail for you
it just accepts that role and they live
like they live common lies and those
lies continue to go and like another
common lie is like that common could be
a good actor
it's okay with it there are two types of
people i think there are
but you know i um an ex of mine bro he
is this was two years ago brendan
schwab's youngest child was born in 2019
oh boy
yep this might be right this might line
up such a tolerant person that he just
doesn't want to engage in any type of
like difficulty
he said it like
and he has two kids now like
that's kind of what you would say if
somebody just had a second e you know
what i mean yeah
avoids confidence they have two kids now
if they have [ __ ] two eight-year-olds
you know what i mean
well i think you see there
but you know i um an ex of mine
he is such a tolerant person that he
just doesn't want to engage in any type
of like difficulties that he means he
avoids
and it's probably every ex of yours is
probably like that because that's the
only people you could date kaleila or
people that you could dominate or that
you made at a family reunion because
that's pretty much your dating pool at
this point yeah it's either people that
look like your family or are your family
you you forgot the spca or the spca
that's a good point hey make sure you're
gonna jerk off a dog you get it from the
pound i don't want you getting any
designer dogs to jerk off delilah adopt
don't shop yeah seriously
you don't have to be a jerk in more than
one way
cause you know dog decks
hi this is kalila from trash tuesdays
coming to you to talk to you about the
red rocket humane society
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] the only thing kalila is a
specialty in his [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yeah i think asians do that a
lot too like you know what you're right
we just kind of
you think delilah
has like has like a [ __ ] relationship
with with dogs that are on death row and
they write some letters because she
thinks she could fix them
uh literally uh
so anyway that was the update on that i
i i just i not update i mean that's old
it looked old like i said from the from
that but i was like what the [ __ ] man